mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
die teure skulptur freue ich mich dass
heißt adrian gott ist es der mensch der
gott lobpreisen freute sich am tag mit
dem fisch und auch im beruf oder
schaffte nur der abstimmung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie sich nichts kartenslot
muss nicht heißen dass ich das gut
finden überhaupt nicht ich finde die
kunst dieser natur auch interessant
halte dass man aber falls sie zum teil
vergänglichkeit nicht nur von der kunst
sondern vor allem wo es menschen
in bad ragaz gz nur rot-weiß-rot
die stecken
[Musik]
im garten würdiges kunstwerk stelle wo
schneller
als ich sein
mit sänger michael von der heide am
kunst open air in bad ragaz
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz
kunstschauen an der frischen luft das
feiert hochkonjunktur und den besten
beweis dazu liefert bad ragaz der kurort
hat sich mit einer kunst triennale
richtig großes renommée verschafft von
hier aus sprechen wir heute über länder
und über die lust an der kunst und zwar
mit sänger michael von der heide
[Musik]
michael von der heides ist ihnen bekannt
vor der bühne schoss vorbei der wald mit
ihrem wunderschöne chansons
sie sind aber auch box und handel ganz
speziellen bezug zur stelle ja das habe
ich bin ich aufgewacht und ich befehle
den park sie damals habe ich so weist
das neue kennt wo die das bad ragaz
lagarde es ist eine sache
die ich werde sagen was man denkt man
ist jetzt richtig zeichnet
wenig begründet vor allem mit ihrer
tochter gaia hohmeister wo grinst er die
nicht für mich auch schon gemacht und
mir stand davor mein kunstwerk vor ihre
und das tut mir besonders
interessant und schön mir gefällt
besonders dass man wenn man ist ganz
besonders kriegt man nicht kennt
man ja eigentlich das geschichten im
norden sind überhaupt das gesicht immer
mehr findet ja immer nur die farbe
wunderschön und die hund plötzlich und
denn wenn wir zurück
gestand
tut sich ein weil du ja eigentlich ist
gesicht und genannt ist montag
vorstellen dass man reber meter distanz
besser gefällt als ist der große held
der partie stand
aber sicher oftmals im leben so also
wenn man deine gedruckt sind sachen wie
gehe ich woanders oder eine sache besser
erklären das ist wahr können sie das als
ihre eigene vita so verstellt absolut es
ist das ja nicht nur kunst die nervigste
kontext vor der naturen oder roma was
verändert dass für sie das natürlich
toll ich stets auf ihr kind den park und
als kind im wald oder wie der bergung
sieht auch kunst oder in der natur aber
mit sechs sicher oder skulpturen und
später
machte manchester materialien und stress
also das hat für mich ein sehr schönes
und auch natürlich haben wir sie dann
bis die luft
[Musik]
allein dort ausstellungen gibt es in der
schweiz inzwischen viele ja und auch die
twinkle and art in wallis ist seit 14
jahren eine feste größe jeden sommer
zieht sich viele interessierte an und
ist auch ein touristischer faktor im
abgelegenen binntal und dort gibt es
dieses jahr eine ganz neue attraktion
die wildromantische twingo schlucht im
walliser binntal
objekte von künstler innen aus der
region aus der schweiz und auch aus dem
europäischen umland ziehen den weg
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob einige von euch schon
mal hier waren im inntal
die kuratorin lucia kahlen begrüßt heute
eine schulklasse aus
brigachtal
endlich die landschaft das kunstschaffen
die sich mit der landschaft genannt
setzte sich durch die landschaft
reagieren das ist ja niemand schöne
naturlandschaft sondern
kulturlandschaft mit
dabei auch salima hänni studentin an der
hochschule der künste bern mit einer
kollegin hat sie ein interaktives
programm entwickelt erst anschauen dann
mit gestalten doch zuerst müssen die
smartphones deponiert werden
die klasse 2c des kollegium spiritus
sanctus ausblick macht sich zuerst ein
bild von der ausstellung es sind
gymnasiastinnen mit dem schwerpunkt
bildnerisches gestalten
trotzdem sind nicht alle mit landart
vertraut aber
die arbeiten lösen reaktionen aus wie
von den kunstschaffenden beabsichtigt
[Musik]
dass man mit natürlich alles macht seit
jahren verschiedenste jetzt
aber steht und das sowieso
[Musik]
schon zum 15 mal findet die dringend art
statt
längst eine feste größe im
landschaftspark binntal im oberwallis
und
ein wichtiger touristischer faktor im
konzept des sanften tourismus
[Musik]
dass sich die
sieben großen stellenwert bekommt das
geht sehr scharfsinnig mio und vor
deinem herzen es ist noch künstlich
keine thema aufbereitet was im schnitt
unbedingten ruhm hat aber laut gäste
sich deine mit dem thema befassen und
verdammen hc ist es wirklich sehr
abkommens und bis heute praktisch
es ist sicherlich ein publikumsmagnet
und wir haben und natürlich zwei
gästegruppen mutter damit keine abholen
einer sitzt ihr war vor ort sind wo mehr
aufmerksamkeit machen sagen sie dazu
übrigens noch die umstellung erst
bekannt ist verliert laufen sie der tour
association und die anderen sind
wirklich viele oberwallis war das alter
sieht er viele jahre aber das geht das
kennen und werden explizit für die
zwingend auf der hand
jetzt dürfen die smartphones iran
führen zur aufgaben für eigene kleine
kreationen
es soll eine ungewohnte perspektive sei
gar nicht so einfach besonders wenn die
eigenen ansprüche hoch sind
[Musik]
und da wir die sich heraus schafft ley
die ergebnisse können auf eine website
hochgeladen werden so entsteht eine
zweite ausstellungsebene mitmachen geht
doch von zu hause aus
das ist wirklich hier kassiere dass die
aufgabe hier keine arbeit hat und hier
auch
möglich
sein kronawitter hämisch passiert
und so das analoge digitaler
form jetzt
bestellen
[Musik]
natürlich das noch
dazu ist das ganze noch so wie letztes
jahr
standen
am ende des tages nach einer kleinen
präsentation gibt es ein gewinner bild
und viele neue eindrücke
saison von ewald dass andere wichtige
für kunst geht nicht immer also das bild
mal und ich glaube das ist ein film
anschaue so das tier was für kunst die
idee hängt das man einfach das bild
morgen das ist das so fertig und seit er
mir gezeigt dass es verschiedene
gerichte gegeben dass er nicht sehr
spannende saison also ich fände es war
sehr interessant weil ich hatte noch nie
land 8 gesehen und ja das war ein tolles
des parlaments führung gibt es noch bis
mitte oktober
interessierte schulklassen können sich
anmelden und auch nächstes jahr wird die
twingo schlucht wieder mit viel
inspirierender kunst bespielt werden
[Musik]
der unterschiedlichste initiant vor der
freiluft durch stelle ich da im bad
ragaz der roll frau meister gratuliere
zu ihrem großen erfolgen mit der
triennale der erfolg ist auch ein erfolg
für tourismus was heißt das konkret
also kultur haben wir eigentlich nicht
die zahlen messen aber ich habe das
gleiche zahlen zeigen es gibt das studio
vor der fachhochschule graubünden wo
zeigt dass die kultur als fünf monate
zur millionen wertschöpfung aber das
bedeutet für uns vor allem die familie
ging wo das organisieren
kulturhaus als tourist ist für drücken
ist sie entwickelt und früh es ist ganz
wichtig dass geistige ist genauso
wichtig wie das manche kaufen die ein
familienbetrieb wirtschaft sehr viel
familienmitglieder mit und teil auch
kunstschaffende sinnlos der familie
hohmeister ist das erfolgsgeheimnis das
erfolgsrezept oder sitzen andere also
sichere ist es die gute partnerschaft
wird die familie will ohne bestimmte
kultur gemeinschaft nicht existiere und
sie weiterentwickeln
ich sage mal familie ist wie eines
formel 1 team renault fahrer haben wir
nur vorwärts gott und vorratskammer
november fahrrad und fahre kann man nur
wenn man gleichgewicht ist und das
schafft die familie jetzt gibt es also
so meins ja ich nehme wandelt
erwachsener york und die nächste
triennale was ist das ziel also sich
günter meier 24 zu öffnen und der traum
nicht nur weiterentwickeln im sinn von
der organisation sondern nur menschen
mit rookie wasser und nach und auch
etwas über mechanik und es ist gratis
man darf einfach doch nur bis das tolle
ist dass auch einen teil der punkte
erfolgt also sicher ist die menschen
keine chance hätten das glück chronisch
bellone thyrow
niedrigen usa ist das ist ein punkt der
persönliche wie man die kunst begegnen
will und da man in den eigenen standort
dienen wie viel man wartet dass jedes
mal
18 ist es berechnet worden für die
hochschule das rund 540 zur kunst und
künstler klasse hinter einer riesigen
erfolg gratulation und toi toi toi toi
toi toi toi
[Musik]
die skulpturen im freien das gab es
natürlich schon bei den alten griechen
die auch bei den alten ägyptern
nichts neues also unter der sonne
hingegen landschaftskunst im engeren
sinn das ist eine junge kunstform seit
über 50 jahren setzen kunstschaffende
akzente in der freien natur und seither
hat sich einiges verändert
diese kunst passt in keine galerie
man kann sie nicht kaufen nicht überm
sofa hängen und nicht im museum finden
wer sie erleben will muss hinaus in die
weite in die landschaft
ende der 1960 er jahre begannen die
pioniere der land ort zeichen in die
landschaft zu setzen sie waren
inspiriert von den neuen perspektiven
welche die mondflüge liefern
der blaue planet in seiner vollen
ausdehnung ihn machten die
avantgardisten so leinwand zu material
und zum spielplatz für ihre kunst
1970 formte roberts müssen steinmassen
zu einer riesigen spirale im great salt
lake in utah sichtbar auf
satellitenbildern 460 meter lang gegen
den uhrzeigersinn und gegen den
mainstream des damaligen kunstbetriebs
michael heiser bewegte noch mehr als
stein masse
240.000 tonnen für einen spalt einen
riss in der natur eine begehbare
skulptur in der man die wucht des
felsens erleben kann
[Musik]
bei den ersten land art künstlern stand
das rebellische im vordergrund das
monumentale als verweigerung möglich nur
dort wo es platz ohne ende gibt wie beim
blitz welt von world die maria in new
mexico wo eisenstangen über einen
quadratkilometer verteilt blitzer
anziehen wie magnete
ursprünglich wollte land ort die
landschaft umgestalten in sie eingreifen
sie umbauen
[Musik]
mit dem 40 km langen running fence stieß
christo 1976 zumindest längen mäßig in
neue dimensionen vor er war es der land
art populär machte und kommerziell
verwertbar wie hier 2016 am lago di leo
ein mega event für touristen
[Musik]
dass künstler camp der land art mongolia
eine der grössten land art ausstellungen
weltweit
hier zeigen sich die neueren trends es
geht um sozial kulturelle und
ökologische dimensionen um die stellung
des menschen in der natur um seine
kultur im wandel der zeit um das
spannungsfeld zwischen tradition und
fortschritt
alle zwei jahre entwickelt eine
internationale künstler in
zusammenarbeit mit einheimischen neue
projekte
so kann zum beispiel auch musikkultur
eingang finden in die land art wie hier
2018 im zusammenspiel traditioneller
instrumente mit moderner
solartechnologie
in der schweiz hat sich die biennale art
safiental am konsequentesten diesen
neuen ansätzen verschrieben
die kunstprojekte reflektieren die
sozialen und ökonomischen gegebenheiten
des berges und entstehen in
zusammenarbeit mit einheimischen
wie hier 2018 als marianne halter und
mario markus eller ein rückhaltebecken
des kraftwerks als imaginäres motodrom
inszenierten akustisch befeuert durch
das gebrumme einheimischer bienen
oder her als bob gramms maus dem
schotter des staunens eine schale formte
die als schwimmende skulptur dem auf und
ab des stausees folgte
[Musik]
und den besuchern auch als fluch dienen
konnten
das ziel von landrat heute ist nicht
mehr um gestaltung der landschaft
sondern um deutung und
neuinterpretation
[Musik]
michael von der heides bin natürlich
gespannt nach der nach dem spaziergang
durch kunst gibt's ein favorit ja also
mir gefällt wahnsinnig gut da die
esskultur schon die natur
heißt sie also an gott nicht unterwegs
das wird
erinnere dich gerade auf trafen die neue
cd von michael berger weist die parade
bonn wo es auch darum konsumenten wahl
sich also dass man zurück das ist aber
wahnsinnige welt vor hass und wo man
gerade über genau gesagt was ich will
und was ich schwarz
und da bin ich denke was macht der bund
der mit dem war der untere oder finden
oder absprung also was ist ihre
interpretation also wie es heißt adieu
dann krieg ich auch nicht das
doppeldeutige dann ist er dort mit dem
wal und und wann sie zu übertönen das
kunstsprache wirst du
genau so wie das
jetzt kommen wir ja damals auch erbost
das ist ja aber kunst macht
es da aus reflex
wenig will haben das gibt es immer
wieder also dass zum beispiel würde ich
aber so wie ich wohne war schade drum
also warum also soll das alle nordwalder
nach izmir
wenigstens ist liegen
und da im eigenen garten haskamp
[Musik]
wenn es jetzt auch lustwandeln möchten
zwischen kunstwerken im freien die bad
ragaz hier in bad ragaz ist noch bis
ende oktober zu sehen im weiteren haben
wir vier andere ausstellungs tipps für
kunst im freien in der ganzen schweiz
für sie zusammengestellt
lotti im kanton neuenburg
schon beim kassenhäuschen lockt eine
marmorne choralen skulptur von claudia
kommt
auf einem rund dreistündigen parcours
durch die umgebende landschaft sind über
40 kunstwerke zu entdecken zb die weg
seinen wassergeister von rebeccas over
monumental hat marcia leiter den tod der
fliege elsa inszeniert einer figur die
vor jahrzehnten schon in seinem
literarischen werk an die rolle gespielt
hat
olive ist zeigt ein steinernes hilfloses
keynotes eros das den boden unter den
hufen verloren hat
die große freiluft ausstellung alle
pläne findet alle vier jahre statt jetzt
bereits zum achten mal noch bis zum 20
september
im hunger boden wald oberhalb von
engelberg haben zehn künstlerinnen und
künstler mit ihren werken den landrat
markiert
[Musik]
mitten im archaischen wald zu entdecken
das universelle on off symbol des
digitalen zeitalters
[Musik]
wie alle kunstschaffenden hier haben
claudia vogel und matthias mäder
ausschließlich mit natürlichen
materialien aus der umgebung gearbeitet
so verschmelzen die skulpturen auf fast
schon symbiotische weise mit der natur
und der waldlandschaft
auch bis zum 30 oktober
[Musik]
der skulpturenpark des kloster schöntal
in baselland stellt an den sender weiter
seit über zwei jahrzehnten bis dahin der
umgebenden landschaft zu einer
dauerausstellung herangewachsen und wird
stetig weiterentwickelt
[Musik]
einen besonderen akzent setzen die
mythologischen plastiken und der
britischen bildhauerin nicola hex
[Musik]
die skulpturen von renommierten
einheimischen und internationalen
kunstschaffenden und sind ohne
einschränkung ganzjährig zugänglich
[Musik]
nach winterthur findet sich das weiltal
im laufe von 20 jahren hat sich hier
eine skulptur biennale mit schweizer und
internationaler beteiligung etabliert
[Musik]
dieses jahr hat auch roman signer wieder
mitgemacht
[Musik]
sein beitrag eine windfahne aus einem
kajak paddeln und einem feuerwehr
handschuh gefertigt
das motto der aktuellen ausgabe idylle
und künstlichkeit
[Musik]
passend dazu
andrea giuseppe kurtulus luna park
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch bis zum 12 september
[Musik]
ja das war für ausflug zur freiluft
ausstellung hier aber ganz schön waren
sie mit dabei nächste woche dann nehme
ich sie mit zu einem open-air-konzert am
zürichsee 77 bombay street später für
uns auf und gleich jetzt geht's hier
weiter auf sf1 mit der sternstunde
philosophie mit dem hirnforscher gerhard
roth kommen sie gut durch die waffe
tisch
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos